yes
don't get it wet
it's like the first room that i've been
in a year and a half where it's hot
because there's
no i mean yeah
[Music]
yes
yeah he did yeah
[Music]
okay
oh
am
[Music]
um
you like
foreign
is
is
cheers
dude
yes
hi everyone hello happy tuesday
so we have two very special guests
with us again today uh as you know
the biden harris administration i'm just
going to let you all settle in here
okay all right great okay
so as you all know today the biden
harris administration announced key
findings from the reviews directed by
the president's executive order
on america's supply chains the executive
order signed february 24th directed a
whole of government approach
to assessing vulnerabilities in and
strengthening the resilience of critical
supply chains so here to discuss
the immediate actions we will be taking
to promote economic security
national security and create good paying
union jobs by strengthening american
supply chains
our repeat guests back for the second
time they had so much fun the first time
deputy director of the national economic
council samira fasoli
and senior director of international
economics and competitiveness at the nsc
peter harrell okay thanks mayor you're
kicking us off thank you
hi everyone good afternoon and thank you
jen
it is good to be back here at the end of
this whole of government review that we
just undertook of america's supply
chains following
president biden's direction back in
february we said from the beginning that
our approach to supply chain policy
needs to be an integral part of the
president's overarching economic
strategy to grow the economy
from the bottom up in the middle out we
also said that we were not going to
simply be writing reports in this
hundred days and then we're going to sit
on a shelf we're going to be taking
action to address specific supply chain
vulnerabilities
i think today's reports make both those
things crystal clear
to achieve supply chain resiliency we
need to build back better by leveraging
america's greatest strengths
first and foremost american workers
decades of focusing
on labor as a cost to be managed and not
an asset to be invested in
have weakened our domestic supply chains
undermine wages and union density for
workers
and also contributed to companies
challenges finding scaled
talent we must focus on creating
pathways for all americans to access
well-paid jobs
with a free and fair choice to join a
union and bargain collectively
second our diversity we need to unlock
the full potential of the american
people
including making economic opportunities
available across our country
and for women and for people of color
third are small businesses
to build a diverse and healthy ecosystem
of suppliers
we must rebuild our small and
medium-sized business manufacturing base
that has borne the brunt of the
hollowing out of u.s manufacturing
fourth our alliances we need to
diversify our international suppliers
and reduce geographic concentration risk
for too long the us has taken certain
features of global markets
especially the fear that companies and
capital are going to flee to wherever
wages taxes
the pandemically bear the challenges of
this approach and we need to change it
we are committed to working with
partners and allies to decrease the
vulnerabilities in our collective supply
chains
and finally fifth our imagination our
approach to supply chain resilience
needs to look forward to emerging
threats
from cyber security to climate issues
and so we are future proofing and
building back better
second it's clear from these reports
that we need to take action
and today we made a series of
announcements to that effect including
on pharmaceuticals
the department of health and human
services is going to be using its
defense production act authority
and funding appropriated under the
president's american recovery
plan to invest 60 million dollars in
advanced pharmaceutical manufacturing
technologies in r d
on advanced batteries the department of
energy will take steps to advance its
support
for battery research manufacturing and
processing
this is going to include new rules to
ensure that companies that develop new
products
based on federal r d funding manufacture
those products
in the us so what is invented in america
can be made in america by america's
workers
on critical minerals and materials like
lithium and rare earths
that are essential in our fight to
combat the climate crisis we will be
announcing a comprehensive strategy that
includes both
increases in sustainable u.s production
and processing
and working with allies and partners to
increase sustainable global supply
and reduce reliance on geopolitical
competitors across all of our domestic
and international efforts
on minerals we will maintain a
commitment to adhere to the highest
labor and social sustainability
standards and support robust
community engagement in the process
including tribal consultations and here
in the u.s
on semiconductors the department of
commerce will double down on their
ongoing work to convene
industry and work with allies and
partners to increase transparency
communication and trust throughout the
semiconductor supply chain
finally as we move to focus on our one
year reviews
the department of agriculture is
announcing more than four billion
dollars in a robust suite of buildback
better initiatives
focused on building a more fair
competitive distributed and resilient
food supply
chain and food system
third we need to be nimble and be able
to address emerging supply chain issues
at the same time as we're continuing
this work
on these longer supply chain resiliency
strategies
and that is why today we are launching a
new supply chain disruptions task force
to tackle near-term bottlenecks
in the semiconductor home building and
construction transportation
and agriculture and food industries this
task force is going to be led
by three cabinet secretaries secretaries
buda judge raymondo and vilsack
and will bring an all-government
approach to addressing the near-term
supply-demand mismatches we are seeing
in these sectors as the economy
reignites
they will be collaborating closely with
industry labor and other stakeholders
to surface solutions share best
practices and take actions
and we at the white house are going to
be the part their partners by their side
it's going to be nec dpc cea
nsc all of us working with them
throughout our work on supply chains we
have been heartened to see the
bipartisan support for supply chain
security and resiliency
including when the president started
this review by meeting with a bipartisan
group of senators in the oval office
we look forward to working with congress
as we move these ideas into action
before i turn it over to my colleague
and friend peter harrell
i want to note that our report's
findings reinforce the president's call
for making a once in a generation
investment in our nation's production
and innovation infrastructure
those investments proposing the american
jobs plan and the american families plan
will strengthen the public systems that
connect manufacturing
researchers workers and small businesses
and will help unleash the power and
ingenuity of the private markets
to drive towards national resiliency
thank you peter
[Music]
good afternoon thanks samira
and it's a pleasure for me to be here
this afternoon this is a signature
initiative for president biden
he has focused on supply chain
resilience since his campaign
when he promised almost a year ago that
if elected he would direct his
administration to expand investments in
u.s
manufacturing and to take other steps to
strengthen the resilience of u.s supply
chains
earlier today pursuant to executive
order 14017
the president biden signed in february
we released publicly 250 pages
of reports assessing supply chain
vulnerabilities
and making recommendations including
immediate actions
to address them earlier this morning
national security adviser jake sullivan
and national economic council director
brian deese
convened a meeting of many members of
the cabinet here at the white house in
the roosevelt room
to discuss the recommendations in this
report and for the cabinet members
to commit to taking action across the
u.s government
to implement those recommendations and
other critical steps
to address supply chain resilience well
the president's
supply chain initiative has identified a
number of vulnerabilities
i want to stress that our work has also
found
that the united states is well
positioned to rebuild our productive
capacity
in key sectors and to strengthen our
innovative leadership
we're confident that working together
with congress industry labor and other
stakeholders
we can chart a new path that emphasizes
resilience
security broad-based growth and
sustainability
as samira mentioned the president and
the entire administration
welcome the strong bipartisan support
that exists on capitol hill
for strengthening american supply chain
resilience
samira highlighted a number of the
domestically focused specific actions
that the administration announced
earlier today
i want to briefly discuss just a few of
the actions that we're taking
internationally as samira said america's
allies and partners are great strength
of our nation and we must work in
partnership with them on supply chain
resilience
we're announcing today a commitment from
the u.s development finance corporation
to increase high standards overseas
investments
in u.s allies and partners and projects
that strengthen
supply chains we're also asking the u.s
export import bank
to develop a proposal for a new domestic
finance window that would
if approved by exims board provide
financing to build manufacturing
facilities and infrastructure
here in the us that will support u.s
exports of critical products
which will help our allies and partners
we're going to be increasing our
diplomatic
work with our allies and partners on
supply chain security
supply chain security will feature
prominently on the agenda
for president biden's trip to europe
starting later this week
including at the u.s eu leaders summit
scheduled for early next week
and was already a major element of
president biden's summits earlier this
spring
with key u.s allies in asia we're also
recommending that president biden host a
global forum at the head of state level
to convene key global leaders to
strengthen supply chain cooperation
finally we know that as we strengthen
cooperation with our allies and partners
we also have to push back against unfair
trade practices by competitor nations
that have hollowed out the u.s
industrial base and
undermine our supply chain security
we're launching a u.s trade
representative
led supply chain trade strike force to
identify
unfair trade practices that undermine
u.s supply chains
and to identify a specific trade actions
we can bring to combat those practices
we're also asking the commerce
department to evaluate a section 232
action on neodymium magnets
which are essential to motors and a
range of defense and industrial
applications
to identify tools to reduce our foreign
dependency
this would demonstrate the type of
targeted but tough action we expect
the trade strike force to deliver i want
to thank
members of the cabinet and their staff
who contributed to these reports and
actions
the initiative represents an immense
amount of work and we know we have much
more in the weeks
and months ahead we'll be working to
implement
all of the recommendations uh summarized
in the report and carrying
forward the work to a second phase
directed by eo14017
which is already underway and consists
of broad studies of the supply chain
risks
of six key industrial-based sectors
those industrial based sector supply
chain reports will be due next february
on the year mark of executive order
1417.
it's been an honor for all of us to work
on this initiative and i'm sure we'll be
talking about it with you regularly as
our work goes
forward thank you and we look forward to
a couple of questions
okay go ahead phil thank you um probably
for sure flesh out a little bit the
supply chain disruptions task force
obviously
you guys believe what's happening right
now is transitory these mismatches exist
they're creating
near-term problems do you expect this
task force to be coming up with ideas
and proposals
in real time are they reporting at a
specific clip how do you expect this to
work to try and address these things
that are problems
right now yeah um well one um
i want everyone to remember and
recognize that these are kind of
good problems to be having um at this
time last year we had bare grocery shops
and we had people going hungry and
thanks to the
the president's american rescue plan um
we have people finally able to
be out there moving again visiting
families this summer
and going out to eat so these are these
are good problems to be having and to be
working
working on right now we're thankful for
that um and the success of our cover
vaccination strategy
um but um i think if what you just saw
us do right now is a 100 day sprint
around four products
and uh when we say we're going to take
sprints and take actions we mean a
sprint and we mean action
and so here our cabinet secretaries who
are in the lead you'll see in the days
and weeks ahead
they are going to be bringing together
all stakeholders to really diagnose the
problems understand what's going on out
there
in these markets and see what actions
can be taken to close those
vulnerabilities
we recognize that in in some instances
those actions are going to be actions
that the
private sector other stakeholder groups
they need to be the ones taking action
the answer is not always
government taking the action here but we
are we have learned in our work with the
semiconductor kind of producers and
users that when you bring people
together
you help them increase trust increase
transparency
and stimulate a lot of learning that
sparks action
april um this is for samara and peter
uh samara you use the word weekend
and as we're talking about supplies i'm
looking at the link with
inflation um what should the american
consumer be looking for now as we've
come up with this
report and the weaknesses that you
talked about as it relates to inflation
and then peter for you you used words
vulnerability
with putting weakened and vulnerability
together there's some kind of economic
uh parallel with this where are we
economically in this nation what is our
status we are saving off
or have been trying to stay off
depression where are we economically are
we still
in recession deep recession where are we
if you can answer both of those
questions
look i think where we are economically
is
the us is clearly the engine of global
growth right now our economy has
reignited
and the rest of the world is um
being valued by our successes here so
i the the economy is fundamentally in a
position of strength but this president
had president has consistently said
that what we need to do is take this
moment to build back better so when we
talk about weaknesses and
vulnerabilities in this report
we've identified structural long-term
problems that have built up over time in
our economy
and that is why this president has been
out there
calling for congress to take action on
his american jobs plan an american
family's plan because what we need now
is a transformational investment to make
sure we can actually grow from the
bottom up
in the middle out peter do you want it
peter
inflation oh you know on these uh supply
chain bottlenecks that we're seeing
these uh some of these prep these price
dislocations these
um temporary increases in delivery time
we fully expect
these bottlenecks to be temporary in
nature and to resolve themselves over
the next few weeks like if
um again these are good problems to be
having demand came back much quicker
than even companies expected
i think the success of our vaccination
campaign surprised many people and so
they weren't prepared for
demand to rebound um in this way but we
still expect this to be
transitory in nature we're going to keep
an eye on it but we think it should
resolve in the next few months
and the status of where we are
economically recession stabilized
depression deep recession where where
are we
i think samara addresses okay strength
strength
okay good job a little bit more about
the semiconductor portion of this
i mean and i'll point you to on on
friday the oecd report we're like the
one advanced economy that
i think um our growth projections are
above where we were at the
pandemic was it 6.9 so good job uh on
semiconductors have you had to balance
funding or support for foreign
manufacturers allies partners and
domestic
manufacturers is there going to be a
preference given to domestics or is
there a risk that this could
you know support foreign manufacturers
in a way that actually undercuts the
domestic industry how if at all you plan
on balancing that
um so i think we are taking an all of
the above strategy to semiconductor
manufacturing and expanding
semiconductor manufacturing
uh both here in the united states and
abroad
as you know the president has called for
congress to appropriate at least 50
billion dollars to strengthen
semiconductor manufacturing here
in the united states including both
leading edge semiconductors
and also some of the more mature
semiconductors where we're seeing
current shortages for
automotive manufacturing and industrial
uh applications
generally speaking uh consistent with
the proposal in in
um in uh in congress we would expect to
encourage both
foreign and american companies to invest
here in the united states and i think
we're already seeing some announcements
of that where we've seen announcements
from intel
from samsung from global foundries from
a whole range of both foreign and
american companies
to expand capacity here but it isn't
just from an overall strategy that money
is going to be about attracting capacity
here in the united states
but from our overall strategy it's not
only about expanding capacity here in
the united states it's also about
working with allies and partners
yesterday for example bosch the major
european automotive supplier
opened a new automotive semiconductor
factory in germany that's going to help
alleviate
some of the global shortages we're
seeing so well that money is going to
lead
to greater production here in the united
states and we are expecting to see a
major increase in production over the
next couple of years this is also an
area where we see opportunities to work
with allies and partners
in a semi-conductive plant equally
whether the investor was a foreign
company or an american
so we expect that the incentives will be
available um
on a competitive basis to both foreign
and american companies
um i'm not here to get into the
specifics of exactly how the program
will be implemented
if congress in fact uh passes uh passes
it
can you talk a little bit about the
trade strike force what are they tasked
with doing
or uh or able to do that ustr doesn't do
already
so i think the the trade strike force is
a vehicle
to leverage a number of our existing
trade
tools but to really focus them on supply
chain vulnerabilities you know we have
as we looked across
uh the four products that we are
releasing reports on today we saw
example after example where an unfair
foreign competitor action had led to the
hollowing out
of a supply chain for key us product
and these are all often very specific
things those foreign governments are
doing so what this
is going to do is harness and focus
uh the government agencies involved in
trade enforcement on how do we use our
trade tools
uh to strengthen to combat unfair trade
practices that
supply chains and to strengthen u.s
supply chains and i think the neodymium
uh magnet uh 232 we're asking commerce
to evaluate
uh is an example of that through our
reports we identified a very specific
product where there's a very specific
supply chain vulnerability and we're
getting the task force to look at that
brian i guess the
disruption task force are you all going
to be looking at ransomware
attacks and how will you deal with it
internationally
on ransomware the disruption task force
is focused on semiconductors
uh lumbering construction or home
building and construction materials it's
not going to focus on
ransomware and cyber security we have a
whole other process
in place led by our national security
council that addresses cyber security
risks and issues and internationally
you'll deal with that how so i think you
saw
the other day deputy national security
adviser
neuberger uh talk about some of the
steps uh that the administration is
taking to address ransomware
um she is leading a process to identify
um and um close vulnerabilities
that we face from ransomware one of the
sets of issues we have been looking at
in our supply chain review both on these
four products and in our
year-long industrial base is cyber
security risks to our supply chains
clearly cyber security risks can
disrupt uh supply chains but um
ms newberger is leading the sort of
focused response to the ransomware uh
issue
yeah that'll be two siloed two different
things are they working together
i would we work very closely i think
peter and i being up here shows you how
closely the national economic council
national security council
worked together on issues where it makes
sense for us to come together and so on
cyber security you have seen
us behind the scenes working together to
figure out how we can leverage our tools
and our convenient power to have a whole
government response repeatedly
okay last one right in the middle go
ahead um
sorry the bully administration um
unbundle work on unbundling large
contracts to ensure that black owned
companies can compete for them
you know so
we are very focused on trying to make
sure that our build back better agenda
sorry it's hard to say
is it okay if i stand here to be able to
look yeah
i relate um no we are
um we are really focused on
making sure that as we talk about
diversifying supplier bases here in
these reports
that we are not just talking about small
businesses but we're talking about
disadvantaged businesses as well
so you've seen in our american jobs plan
that we
put um proposals in there related to
small business and strengthening
strengthening small business and we know
an important piece of that is leveraging
federal procurement and the power of
determinism
um you talked about the exporting port
bank and some of the financing
is going to be done to shore up
industrial manufacturing here in the
united
states under the previous administration
though china
was one of the top destinations of u.s
export and port financing
an overwhelming majority of that money
actually came to state-owned enterprises
is the administration looking at
anything in terms of financing
that that goes to some of these um
industries overseas
shouldn't you know the priority making
certain that money stays here
so that's actually exactly the proposal
we're asking the export
banks board to evaluate is a new window
that would
foster direct ex-im bank financing for
the construction of manufacturing and
infrastructure here in the united states
obviously they have a long-standing set
of programs that finance the export of
products made in the united states to
foreign uh foreign buyers but actually
it's exactly what we're asking to look
at as ways to expand the financing for
construction
and investment here in the u.s thank you
both so much for joining us
appreciate it
thank you okay um
just two more items for all of you at
the top um yesterday in guatemala city
city following a bilateral meeting with
the guatemalan president the vice
president
announced a new effort to partner with
guatemala around security economic
development and anti-corruption
today in mexico the vice president will
hold a bilateral meeting
with president obrador they'll discuss
our economic relationship
security cooperation and stemming
migration the vice president and
president obrador will witness the
signing of a memorandum of understanding
between the united states and mexico
to establish a strategic partnership to
cooperate and development programs in
the region
and the vice president will also meet
with labor leaders women entrepreneurs
and u.s
embassy
one last item for all of you we have
more good news on the global fight
against covet 19. today the mastercard
foundation and mastercard pledged to
make a 1.3 billion
contribution to help make critical
progress in providing vaccines to people
across africa
in partnership with the africa centers
for disease control and prevention
this is a significant commitment to
acquire covid19 vaccines for at least 50
million people
and to build long-term manufacturing and
equitable distribution capacity
which will further enable efforts to
provide vaccines and strengthen the
continent's ability to prepare for
future
pandemics this is a welcome addition to
our announcement last week that
approximately 5 million of our first
tranche of covet 19 vaccines
will be shared with african countries in
coordination with the african union
which vaccines uh they're providing
funding a contribution of funding uh to
to uh ensure that these uh vaccines are
uh are provided to africa i don't have
whichever vaccines they take it's again
funding to the africa cdc
version of the cdc so uh it will be
distributed through there
uh with that darlene why don't you kick
us off thank you
uh have the president and senator capito
had their conversation yet
and what can you tell us about it if
they have they have not had a
conversation yet but they will have a
conversation
uh this afternoon um and uh the
president looks forward to
uh just continuing the discussion with
the senator
uh he appreciates her good faith
engagement over the last few weeks
i would reiterate as was noted in the
statement we put out last week
that while the president came down by
quite a bit
uh in his proposal from his initial
proposal
on the american jobs plan the latest
offer that we had seen from
senator capito's group uh did not meet
the essential needs of our country to
restore roads and bridges prepare us for
a clean energy future
and create jobs so today they'll have a
discussion about
what more there is to discuss i guess
and
what the path looks like for it i will
also note that the president will also
speak with
other senators this afternoon still
finalizing who those will be and we'll
have
readouts of that as well uh um who have
been engaged in discussions about a
bipartisan infrastructure proposal
engaged with each other so he'll have
those discussions as well
i expect we'll have a readout as i noted
we're encouraged by these discussions
and see them as
an additional viable path forward and
he'll ask members of his jobs cabinet or
he's already asked them i should say
to remain engaged in the days ahead the
period of time when he's on his foreign
trip although of course he'll remain
engaged from there as well
with all members who are interested in
working together on making a historic
investment uh in infrastructure and just
third piece i would note darlene as
we're kind of
um since you asked about the president
engagement he's also going to stay
closely engaged with
democratic leadership about the path
forward especially in light of the
markup on
the surface transportation bill
happening tomorrow in the house and the
interest by speaker pelosi leader
schumer
and other leaders in congress on moving
forward and certainly an interest in
doing that
finally last thing i would note is the
expected passage
later today of the u.s innovation and
competitiveness act
in the senate this afternoon which is a
down payment
on the president's proposed investment
in r d to make us more competitive
as well as the important work with
senator that senator wyden has
undertaken
on clean energy tax credits a priority
the president
shares so i would just note as i've
stated many times before and here
there are a number of paths for moving
the president's bold ideas forward
we're moving on all of them full speed
ahead one more question sure
since the president is the head of the
democratic party uh would he support
legislation that is now on the
governor's desk in nevada that would
move
nevada to first place in the
presidential primary process
up from third place i certainly
understand the interest but i'm not
going to weigh in on the order of uh
presidential primary
contest from here uh go ahead on the
infrastructure talk
senator campono said she's not going to
be coming to this conversation armed
with
a new offer as you note the president
has rejected the republicans latest
counteroffer it doesn't seem
that he's willing to come down any
further so are we at an impasse here
we certainly don't see it that way he's
looking forward to discussing the path
forward with
senator capito he sees her as an
important and uh viable
uh partner as we look to how we're gonna
get uh his bold ideas uh signed into law
and again i'd note that there's also
democrats and republicans as you have
seen and many of you have reported on
who are discussing what how they can
work together on what a path forward
would look like
where there might be more investment in
clean energy jobs
and might be a higher number than what
we've seen by the proposals to date so
again there are a lot of a lot of paths
forward uh
and he looks forward to discussing uh
what they look like with senator capito
and others this afternoon
is the president though willing to offer
any other concessions in these
negotiations or is it safe to say that
you view
the ball as being in the republicans
torture look i think this is
as any negotiation is it's about both
sides looking to see
how much they can come to the other side
and how much you have to give
the president has come down by about a
trillion dollars that's quite
a bit um obviously we'd like to see more
uh but there are
a number of opportunities and paths to
have these discussions moving forward
i wonder just broadly uh if you could
explain a little bit more how the
president has been preparing
for this big trip tomorrow uh how much
time has he been spending in briefings
just sort of how has he uh been getting
ready
well first i will say that he's been
getting ready for 50 years
um he has been on the world stage he's
known a number of these leaders for
decades uh
including president putin and including
a number of the leaders he'll see at
nato
and he'll see at the g7 now this is an
important opportunity
for him to see them in person and
there's nothing like face it to face
engagement in diplomacy and for him
somebody who as you've seen
the fact that he's welcomed and
democrats and republicans to the oval
office that's just an indication
of how much he feels that format is
effective
uh so he's been engaging with his team
talking about what bilateral
conversations he'll be having
where there are opportunities where
there are moments to uh
voice the united states uh concern where
necessary
uh but again he's uh he's got quite a uh
a several decades of experience to build
on here so
um you know he'll be relying on that in
the in during his trip go ahead phil
secretary grant home on sunday said that
it was frustrating that
a pathway for a bipartisan deal hadn't
come to fruition yet does the president
share that frustration at this point
well i would say the president has a
benefit of 36 years in the senate where
he
has seen that the sausage making is
messy it takes time their ups and downs
in the roller coaster we're right in the
middle of the sausage making right now
um and the president's view is that uh
it's a good sign
that there are several viable paths
forward that we are having
good faith conversations of course with
democrats and our democratic
colleagues and partners but also with a
number of republicans
that's a good sign at the same time uh
the house
is moving forward with marking up key
components of the american jobs plan so
the fact is this train is moving on
several tracks
that's how we know these uh larger
packages larger proposals often move
forward
and uh we're encouraged by uh the
variety of options
along the lines of the sausage making
given the scale of the president's
ambitions
with the proposals on the table is the
real reason that he's still in
bipartisan negotiations right now
because moderate democrats are saying
we need to stay in bipartisan
negotiations right now or does he think
something can come
the president wouldn't be spending his
time engaging in hours of discussions
with
republicans if he didn't think something
could come from it now we can't predict
what the final outcome is and we're
keeping
his only uh lines in the sand as you
know phil are in action
uh and raising taxes on americans making
less than four hundred thousand dollars
a year we know
there is there are a lot of democrats
who are eager to move forward as are we
but we think there are a lot of paths
forward where we can where it's worth
continuing to pursue a bipartisan
discussion
go ahead thank you about that vice
president's trip why is it that
uh that when the vice president is asked
if she has plans to visit the border
she says we've been to the border even
though she has not as vice president
well as the vice president she does
speak for uh the actions of the people
in administration she certainly helps
oversee
i expect that sometimes she may go to
the border peter but as you know what
her focus has been what the assignment
is specifically is to
work with leaders in the northern
triangle she's on a trip doing exactly
that
exactly what the president asked her to
do and as we understand it though
her main focus is to try to address the
root causes
of migration did somebody decide here
that it would not be helpful for her
to go to the border and talk to people
who just migrated here
well again i think that uh at some point
she may go to the border we'll see
but she's in the northern triangle now
to have discussions with leaders with
uh community leaders with civil society
leaders
uh with the embassy about how we can
work together and
obviously she's made a couple of
announcements already probably more to
come before she comes back to the united
states
and she described though that you said
she might go to the border she described
a trip to the border yesterday as a
grand
gesture why look peter again i think
her focus of this trip is on meeting
with leaders having a discussion about
how to address corruption how to address
the root causes how to work together to
address
humanitarian challenges in these
countries that's exactly what she's
doing on the ground and i'm sure she'll
report back to the president when she
returns go ahead
i'm gonna follow up with the border in a
second but let me ask you if i can on
infrastructure you laid out some of the
conversations that the president is
having including sort of his message to
some of the democrats
on capitol hill right now to sort of get
a little better
detail there would the president's
support does he want democrats to more
actively pursue the process
of reconciliation as an option well uh
peter i would say that uh
the democrats are already moving forward
on marking up components of the bill
and democratic leadership has been clear
that they want to move forward on
infrastructure and making a historic
investment in infrastructure
there'll be a discussion about the
mechanics of that uh you know over the
course of the coming days
and we'll have more to read out once
those discussions have been hacked
in terms of like the time frame for
those decisions to be made
obviously the message just democrats is
keep going and we might need you well
look i think to be clear
the president's always going to continue
to pursue opportunity to work with
republicans regardless of what mechanics
are moving forward
in the house um he's going to keep
pursuing those opportunities and
we fully expect that there will be
several pathways uh
that are moving on different channels as
we look to how we're going to get this
american jobs plan passed
as it relates to the border right now we
heard from the vice president yesterday
where her message was very simple and
blunt she said to those migrants who
would be considering
coming she said do not come obviously
there's some progressive democrats
among other critics who've been
frustrated by that alexandria
ocasio-cortez perhaps
most prominently saying it was
disappointing to see she said among
other things
that seeking asylum at any us border is
a 100 legal method
of arrival what does the white house say
to those progressive democrats among
others
who are frustrated by the message the
white house is delivering well first of
course it is and one of our focuses and
the priorities of the president and the
vice president is to
improve asylum processing at the border
to work with a range of democrats and
hopefully republicans because in history
it's been a bipartisan effort to get
immigration reform passed to make
ensure there's a more viable pathway to
citizenship and a better processing
at the border what the vice president
was simply conveying
is that there's more work to be done
that we don't have these systems in
place yet
it's still a dangerous journey as we've
said many times
from here and from many forums before
and
uh we need more time to get the work
done to ensure that asylum processing is
where it should be
last question about the senate report
bipartisan senate report as it relates
to what happened on january 6th
obviously it addressed
the security planning the response
failures
we know that that's held up on capitol
hill right now your reaction to that and
what if anything more of the white house
can do
as it relates to those security failures
in terms of planning
well uh first let me just reiterate that
of course the events of january 6 were
an assault on our democracy in the rule
of law
and the president has been outspoken and
calling for a full and independent
investigation to what transpired
as it relates to the report our team is
currently reviewing the report and its
findings to inform our ongoing efforts
to ensure something like that
could never happen again and what role
of course the federal government can
play there are many roles as you know
that
the report seems to surface on uh on
what officials on capitol hill could do
and we want to assess how we can be a a
good partner
in this effort moving forward i would
also note that um
on his first full day in office he asked
his team to launch review on how we can
prove the federal government's response
to
the threat of domestic terrorism
something he also touched on when he was
in tulsa
last week and will be releasing that
broader strategy soon as well
uh go ahead thank you jen the fda has
still not
cleared the 60 million astrazeneca doses
that are part of
the president's commitment to share 80
million doses overseas by the end of
june
is there any concern that the
administration will not get that
approval from the fda in time and if
that were the case
uh will the u.s then make up for those
60 million
doses with other available vaccines in
order to meet the president's
deadline of the end of june right well
we as you know can't predict or
expedite the timeline here it's the fda
who will make that decision about when
those doses will be approved if and when
they will be approved uh we do remain
committed to
ensuring that we meet our commitment of
80 million doses
uh getting those out to the global
community by the end of june which is
again five times more than any other
country
and 13 of our own supply it's only june
8th so we have quite a bit of time uh
but
we remain committed to that and
obviously if the fda
approves astrazeneca doses then that
will be a component of that supply
this is a poor question on behalf of our
colleagues at the canadian press as well
as full
news on the timeline for reopening the
u.s canada border
canada said it will look to take a
phased approach does the white house see
an announcement happening in
concert or is the u.s prepared to ease
those restrictions on its own
well again we would make a decision
about the canada border
based on the guidance of our health and
medical experts
and i'm sure that when that decision is
made we would communicate through
diplomatic channels but i don't have
anything to predict about the timeline
go ahead thank you um you've mentioned
how long the president has spent in the
senate he's talked himself about how
timing and
and sequencing things are really key to
presidential leadership
does he have an objection to starting
with hr4 instead of hr1 in other words
why not do the john lewis
act first i think he is quite open
uh to what democratic leadership feels
is the viable path forward and we'll
work closely with them in coordination
there's a difference of opinion on that
on what will be the best
we're not going to be we're not going to
be the arbiters of that but we will
discuss with them
we will discuss with them as we as we
look ahead what the right path forward
is
okay and my second question just on
infrastructure in terms of the people
he's speaking to this afternoon
will one of them be mitt romney uh i
don't
we will give readouts and who of who
he's spoken with once we've completed
those calls but
i don't have anything to preview for you
at this moment wrong has he ever spoken
to him in his life
um uh it's a good question uh he's
spoken with a number of republicans as
you know we don't read them all out
um i i don't have anything to read out
for you but he has
obviously in a different circumstances
in terms of these different paths and
different groups
this group that he's going to talk to
yeah this afternoon is this the first
time that he's starting to kind of reach
out to them he's been really focusing on
capital up until now
uh that's right we've been engaged with
a range of democrats and republicans
including
members who have been in conversation
through this group at a staff level
he's obviously had discussions with a
number of them about uh how he moves his
ideas forward so
i wouldn't make it as as firm as a first
time but um
certainly discussing this is a viable
path forward at his level
at this point in the process um you know
would be an indication of of how we see
this as a viable path
go ahead trump just to follow up on the
question on voting rights you said
yesterday that
we will stay lockstep with the
democratic leadership on that path
forward
um and and what pelosi said in her
letter today is that
the hr4 is not going to be ready until
the fall
so are you and to focus just to focus
effort on passing hr1
so are you okay with that kind of time
frame is that
even if that means that basically this
issue languishes until the fall
well first we don't see it as
languishing obviously the president has
asked the vice president to lead this
effort and
i'll give you a bit of an update that in
addition to
of course engaging with federal effort
efforts on the federal level to move
legislation forward
she's also going to use the power of the
white house to convince key stakers
holders and she'll be hosting uh several
events uh
next week when she returns from her
trips just to give you an indication of
how quickly
and how focused we will be on these
efforts and so she'll fight
um for our key bills and also to
register
um voters under the president's historic
executive order as well as advocate for
democratic principles so
i will say we're going to work of course
with democratic leadership on both on
both
even with their disagreements about the
the what the order of events should be
here
but we're not going to wait for that
we're going to
use the white house as a convener we're
going to use the bully pulpit obviously
when the president was in tulsa just
last week
he talked about voting rights very
passionately and forcefully
i'll also note that we're also
continuing to work to implement
the executive order that the president
signed into law early on in his
administration and
that executive order uses every
authority available to make voting
easier more accessible and more fair it
directs agencies to expand
access to voter registration and
election information
assist states under the national voter
registration act
improves and modernizes vote.gov
increases federal employees access to
voting
analyzes barriers to voting for people
with disabilities increases voting
access from
active duty military and other voters
overseas
so i would just note that we are not
relying on just
one option here of course federal
legislation is something he will
continue to press for but
we'll use the bully pulpit we'll use our
convening power we'll continue to press
through on implementing this executive
action as well
separate issue there was a report this
morning about um
basically irs records showing that uh
very wealthy
americans have evaded paying
income tax uh almost all together in
certain circumstances
one do you have any reaction just to
that uh as a factual matter and two
are you concerned about that just from a
leak standpoint
well let me take the second part first
because i think that's important uh any
unauthorized disclosure of confidential
government information by a person with
access is illegal
and we take this very seriously the irs
commissioner said today that they are
taking all appropriate measures
including referring the matter to
investigators and treasury
and the irs are referring the matter to
the office of the inspector general the
treasury inspector general for tax
administration
the fbi and the u.s attorney's office
for the district of columbia all of whom
have independent authority to
investigate so obviously we take it
very seriously i'm not going to comment
on specific
unauthorized disclosures of confidential
government information
i can tell you that broadly speaking
we know that there is more to be done to
ensure
that corporations individuals who are at
the highest income
are paying more of their fair share
hence it's in the president's proposals
his budget
and part of how he's proposing to pay
for his ideas april go ahead
i'm sorry i'll come back to you but i'm
going to follow back up on
voting rights or matters of voting
rights sure this president
has based his administration on equity
and equality and now the issue of voting
rights is
in our face we are voting without the
full protections
of the 1965 voting rights act because of
shelby beholder
but it's also unraveling because of
states
and the person that seems to be holding
it up
is joe manchin is the president planning
to specifically speak with him about
voters not
not including it with infrastructure
anything is he
planning on speaking with him
specifically on voting rights
particularly
after this morning's virtual meeting
with civil rights leaders who say the
conversation will continue
well well first let me say that it was
encouraging to see senator manchin
meeting with civil rights
groups today uh the meeting shows that
both are serious and recognize
the importance of the issue we certainly
know the seriousness that many civil
rights groups take
with voting rights and the importance of
moving this forward uh
and as indicated in both of their
readouts as you said april
they will continue the discussion i i
would certainly expect that when the
president has a conversation with
senator manchin the next time
they'll talk about voting rights um and
uh but
often when he speaks with members he
talks about a range of issues somewhere
you work together somewhere you disagree
so understanding the history of how
presidents
decide to lean in he's got um
vice president harris putting this in
her
portfolio but when will the president
begin to lean in is there a moment where
he has to himself
lean in on this because if it doesn't
happen
before the next elections it looks like
it could be
a done deal you were with the president
in tulsa last week right you heard how
passionately he spoke about voting
rights
uh how central this is to how he views
his presidency his leadership the future
of our democracy
i mean that was central to the message
he delivered uh in a speech that was
widely covered
uh that was reflecting on a moment in
history that hasn't required hasn't
been given the the attention that it
certainly deserves
i i certainly would not say we're
waiting as i noted we're going to
continue to press for federal
action for action uh to move forward on
a
bill that the president would love to
sign into law we certainly know we can't
do that with a magic wand that's not how
democracy works
for good reason but the president also
signed this executive action uh early on
a very expansive and powerful executive
action because he wanted to
uh did not want to delay a moment in
ensuring that we were taking more steps
to
assist states to improve and modernize
vote.gov
to increase federal employees access to
voting to analyze barriers to voting
for a range of people and that was an
action he took early on
we're continuing to implement now and
also note that the vice president
asking his vice president his partner to
play a role in leading this
something that she also asked for just
to be clear uh asked to do
it sends a message about what a priority
this is to the president they have
regular lunches
they engage she's the first in the room
and the last in the room
and she's going to not hesitate either
not to lay either i should say when she
comes back from her trip
she'll be convening people and she will
be elevating these issues
as well uh from her platform go ahead
thank you jen the family reunification
task force has reported that of the
about 3 900
children who are separated from their
families it does not have a confirmed
record
of reunification for 2127 children
can you explain what that means that
they don't have a record of
reunification
does the administration know where these
children are
well first as you know we have from
covering this and i know another
a number of others have one of the
challenges that they walked into or we
walked into is the lack of data
and that we knew that would take some
time to
ensure that we were handling the data
and handling the reunification process
as carefully as possible uh i would note
that through the support of ngos um
1779 children were reunified with their
parents in the united states under past
court orders
over the last 30 days through the task
force and ngo coordination
seven additional children were reunited
with their parents bring the total
number of reunified children to 1786.
uh in terms of where we go from here i
mean i would certainly point you the
task force for what their terminology
means uh we know there's a challenge
with data a challenge with matching that
uh to what we have access to uh but
beyond that i would certainly point you
to the department of homeland security
so you don't know if the administration
is aware of
where these children are that's not what
i said what i said was the department of
homeland security overseas the task
force and i would certainly point you to
them
to give you more of a clear definition
of exactly what they mean by mismatched
data so you have all the information
you're looking for
the justice department president biden
has accused his predecessor of using it
as his own personal law firm
is he disappointed that the doj is
siding with trump
in his claim that he can't be sued for
defamation
for remarks that he made about an
alleged rape case
well first let me say that the president
strongly believes
in the independence of the department of
justice we were not consulted the white
house was not consulted i should say
more specifically
by the department of justice on the
decision to file this brief
or its contents so does he believe that
independence still exists even though
the doj
is defending the former president
i'm not sure what you mean by your
question does he believe that the doj
defending the former president
in this case still maintains that
independence between the executive
branch and i think what i was referring
to is
allowing for the department of justice
to make decisions and announcements
about ongoing
uh you know court filings and uh legal
action
so independence as it relates to how the
this president
views and approaches the department of
justice
i think the president has been pretty
clear as we just started her comment uh
con conveying uh about his view
uh about the president his view about
his predecessor's comments about his
predecessor's language and about his
predecessor's
approach uh and his engagement in that
regard what can you do about it
uh i don't think i have anything more to
speak to you on brian on active
litigation go ahead josh
i asked there was a series of web
outages this morning that linked to a
company called fastly is there any
indication that it's anything other than
just
failure with that company specific is it
a potential national security issue
and you look into whether there's a
potential external group behind it
yeah fastly i know put out a statement
about it i don't have anything more from
the federal government on the leak on
the outage
pivoting to the g7 the president has
talked about the need to push the g7 to
boost vaccine available ability overall
can you speak to
what he's considering prime minister
johnson for instance has talked about
the need to vaccinate the
world in its entirety by the end of 2022
other european leaders
are not going quite so far does the
president have a view on what specific
target the g7 should take
uh well i expect we'll have more in the
coming days
so stay tuned um jake did say he
expected
uh that you all hear more at the g7 i
don't want to get ahead of that too much
but what i would say is that the united
states is
we're headed into the g7 in a position
of strength with 64
of our adult population vaccinated in a
position to
donate more doses to the world than any
other country
around the world but we certainly know
this needs to be a global effort and it
will be a discussion
at the g7 and we'll have more to say in
the coming days go ahead
um just one more infrastructure given
the
you know what senator kavanaugh said
today to reporters from throwing cold
water on
progress between her and the president
on talks would you say the
administration has become more willing
to pursue reconciliation to pass
infrastructure package
uh than than than maybe
well i would say that there are always
there's always been a range of paths uh
to get the president's bold ideas passed
into law
he's having a conversation with senator
capito this afternoon as well as
individual conversations with other
members who have been working in a
bipartisan partisan manner
to see what the path forward looks like
and he's also closely in touch with
democratic leadership so
i'm not here to rule out options but i'm
not here to rule in new options either
we'll have we'll have more to say after
he has these calls
later this afternoon one more um the
white house said over the weekend it was
unaware of the doj gag order on the new
york times
can you assure us that there are no
other gag orders on other news
organizations
um related to some of these
investigations well the department of
justice has made clear that was
their third and final notification that
they were offering and that's the
information they also shared with us but
they've shared it publicly and so there
were
to your understanding there's no other
categories they made
they indicated that this was their last
uh effort their last
notification that they needed to offer
go ahead thanks um so i have a question
that's about little instructor little
climate uh senator sheldon whitehouse
was tweeting yesterday saying that
he was anxious about the future of
climate-related legislation and he said
climate has fallen out of the
infrastructure discussion as it took its
bipartisanship detour it may not return
then he went on to say i don't see the
preparatory work for a close senate
climate vote taking place in the
administration
um has the white house reached out to
the senator and also does he have cause
for concern on the future
of climate-based legislation well i
promise you we are certainly in touch
with his team and
perhaps even on individual basis as well
but i don't have anything to read out
for you but i can just tell you that we
are
in close touch with uh nearly every
member of congress who is working on
these
legislation moving forward i will say
that what i would point out to you
is that one of the one of the um pieces
we conveyed
when uh when we put out a statement last
week about how the president could not
accept
the offer that was put out by um by
senator capito
uh and her group even though those those
conversations are happening in good
faith
was the fact that it didn't do enough to
invest in our clean energy future
and there are areas of effort that are
moving forward i mentioned
senator wyden's effort to move forward
on clean energy tax credits
the president views this bill as a jobs
bill he also
believes it's a clean energy jobs bill
and it has an opportunity to
invest in industries of the future so uh
certainly it is
uh close to his heart it remains an area
he's committed to
and uh one he will continue to fight for
as we have these discussions moving
forward
and then i just found another on uh the
vice president
visiting the border or not visiting the
border um republicans and conservatives
are
you know going crazy on twitter sending
pictures
sending video of her interview with
lester holt you know saying
you know i've not been to europe either
um
does the president think there is a
scenario in which she should visit the
border and also
the mounting criticism from
conservatives does that
would that ever factor into a decision
to send her down there i mean
don't they have a point that if she has
this task in front of her should she not
see the
the end cause as well as the root cause
of well well first of all they said to
peter at some point she may go to the
border i don't have any trips to preview
for you or predict or timeline for that
but what i would reiterate is that her
assignment
was to work with countries and leaders
in the northern triangle to address root
causes
address corruption uh ensure we're
working together to address humanitarian
concerns
i will say we're not taking advice from
former president trump
or most of the republicans who are
criticizing us on this given they were
all sitting there
while we created this problem we walked
into uh both at the border
uh and uh with with the movement of
migration
that has been growing over the last year
so we're not taking our guidance and
advice from them
but if it is constructive and it moves
the ball forward for her
to visit the border uh she certainly may
do that uh go ahead
yeah two uh questions on infrastructure
you said the white house is moving ahead
on all three paths
uh on infrastructure including uh the
third path which was listening to other
uh lawmakers who have ideas i believe
that's how you characterize it
um i'm just trying to clarify this was
asked a little bit earlier i mean are
you referring to the
bipartisan group that consists of
senators mansion
uh cinema romney and portman and if
current talks with senator capito
uh in her group don't progress is there
a point when you stop
negotiating with that group in favor of
this other
group of republicans and democrats is
that how you'd see it working well i
would say
we'll leave it to them to determine what
groups they may or may not want to join
but they're not it's not a closed group
we would welcome anyone who wants to
join that group and be a part of these
discussions moving forward
and uh we'll see where it heads members
of the press i'll leave it to them to
determine i think you have to be an
elected member of the senate so unless
that's your pathway moving
with them though forward yeah okay and
then my second question is what
specific uh proposals uh did the white
house agree to bring down or eliminate
in its latest uh infrastructure calendar
offer that reduced the cost
from 1.7 trillion to 1 trillion in new
spending
does funding specifically for the
funding for caregiving
remain in the president's latest offer
uh and if it does i mean is it still the
400 billion dollar
price tag caregiving uh remains a huge
priority
investing in caregiving to the president
i'm not going to outline any more
specific details other than to convey
that
it's an area he continues to fight for
to advocate for and one that he'd like
to be signed into law as part of a
package moving forward does that mean
it's not part of what you're negotiating
right now with republicans no that's not
what i said i'm not i don't have any
more details to outline for you go ahead
yes um i'm sorry oh we'll we'll go
we'll sorry we'll go to you next the
chief of russia's space
agency is threatening to pull out of the
international space station unless the
united states
lifts sanctions against two companies
that are related
to the space station what's the white
house response to that
it's a really interesting question and i
didn't know much about it before you
asked this question so i'll probably
have to talk to our national security
team i will say that
working together on issues of space and
issues related to space is one area we
have worked together historically with
the russians on
and i'd have to dig more into what those
sanctions are for i'm not aware of a
consideration of that but i'll check
with our national security team
go ahead yamiche thanks so much jen a
follow-up to luigi's question
in four months a family reunification
task force has
reunited about 36 families i'm wondering
um what the white house makes what the
president makes of the aclu saying
it hopes the government increases that
pace the president want to see this
go faster are there any explanations for
maybe why it needs to go slower
we certainly do as i think any member of
the family reunification task force
would want to as well and one of the
challenges has been
what we walked into which was a lack of
data or tracking for a number of these
uh kids that uh were separated from
their parents
when they came across the border over
the last few years that's a huge
data challenge we're not going to
reconnect them with families where it's
not
properly verified right because we know
there's a history
uh over the last several years of you
know kids being connected with pain
with individuals who had male intent uh
so that's a factor yamiche we wish of
course everybody wants it to go faster
everybody wants
in this administration everybody wants
these kids to be reunified with their
family members and with
verified family members uh but you know
we're working with a challenging
issue related to data that we knew would
be the case from the beginning
do you think that pace is going to be
the pace or do you think it will get
quicker
i would certainly point to to them the
members of the task force and the
department of homeland security who are
much
more in depth about where the status is
where the challenges are
and what the holdups are and we can
certainly invite one of them to come and
speak to you at the appropriate time as
well
well i know there's the covenant but in
some ways when you look at
southern states they are lagging
particularly when it comes to
vaccination rates i wonder if the
president
has any sort of plan specifically
targeted to southern states
um and whether or not that will impact
whether or not he moves back the 70
goal that he said for july 4th well
yamiche you're right that there are
different uh
age groups they're different demographic
groups there are different geographic
groups in the country where
we haven't seen the pace as fast as
others so while it's
very high the vaccination rate at this
point among seniors
and even pretty high over 70 for people
40 and older
still young i will note um it is it is
not where it needs to be
and people under 40 and certain states
around the country
what we're trying to do when we just
launched this past weekend is this
uh massive one-month campaign to
incentivize
right uh people getting vaccinated we're
working with the private sector
uh we're going to barber shops we're
working with uh you know
donuts and beer and all sorts of
incentives to get
young people and people vaccinated who
have been either hesitant
resistant or just didn't want to take
the step to get vaccinated
we're going to continue charging through
the finish line to per in pursuit of our
70
goal we've seen 13 states meet that goal
it's ultimately up to
some some these states and some
individuals to get vaccinated to meet it
in a state-by-state basis
um there are some progressives who are
calling joe manchin senator manchin
the new mitch mcconnell saying he's an
obstructionist um saying that he's
standing in the way of the private
agenda
i wonder what the president makes of
that is he worried about progressive
alienating senator manchin or does he
agree with some of the things that
they're saying about standing in the way
of his agenda
look i think uh we're not gonna we're
gonna leave the name calling to others
um the president considers senator
manchin a friend he disagrees with him
on uh voting rights and and the the bill
that
the senator has expressed he won't
support uh the president will continue
to advocate for the importance of that
moving forward
uh and the reasons why uh that it's a
it's a
important and vital for our democracy uh
but
uh you know we'll continue to seek ways
we can work with senator manchin even
in well we have areas of disagreement
the name calling is it alienating the
senator is it worrisome
that you you're hearing democrats say
that about senator manchin calling him
the new mitch mcconnell
is that is that problematic i can't
speak to to senator manchin's personal
the personal impact on senator manchin
he's obviously proud of his independent
streak he's spoken to that including in
an op-ed
piece this weekend i also we also
understand
the passion that many feel for voting
rights for the importance of making
voting easier more accessible
we share that passion uh so we
understand that manifests itself in lots
of ways but
i point you to senator manchin if he's
if he has feelings hurt
i suspect he has a stronger backbone
than that but thank you everyone so much
look forward to
i guess i won't see you for a while
those of you coming on the trip we'll
see you on the trip
thanks everyone good trips
and we feel uh all of us as well as
leaders
of the public utilities commission and
ericot believe that we have achieved
success with regard to weatherizing for
both summer and winter
i can answer for myself uh would be any
pi request that i received
and i know that you feel like
information about what happened
is appropriate given the circumstances
that texans endure
so in a way there's maybe two different
questions in what you ask
i can't tell what you're asked or
questions that have been raised by
public information act
request or general information i'm
asking if you think that information
we have requested multiple media outlets
from the public information act
is a sufficient amount of information
that's been given to the public
and so i have no way of knowing
what has been received by the press
through public information act
requests what i can say is this
and that is anything that the media
wants to ask
you have the right to ask right now
which is why we want to make sure you
have the opportunity
to ask the leaders of the power grid
reform
whatever question you may have two more
questions back to the consumer
protection
program part of this whole bill um
repair relief was stripped from the
final version of the bill
i know you touched us a little bit more
but would you mind kind of explaining
why
that specific portion was was taken out
that portion of direct rate pay relief
was actually in a different bill
that senator hancock was was offering
there's a
spectrum of how much you can backstop
the rate payers the consumers of texas
and there was discussion as to
on the senate side in particular of of
direct rate pay relief as fashioned by a
350
credit on the utility bill uh that's
still something up to for a discussion
it might be
be visited again uh however it didn't
make it across the finish line but it
the larger concept is securitizing and
allowing for spreading out of the costs
both on the natural gas side
as well as on the electric side at
electric co-ops
regular generation and municipal owned
utilities was accomplished and will have
direct impact on rates going forward
keeping those low so there are aspects
about how far legislation can go
and unfortunately that aspect was not
able to be uh accomplished in this
case i'll just point out when we use
that 98 number that includes
that we're on fixed rate plans that
includes commercial properties the vast
majority of those
that were not on fixed rate plans are
commercial type properties and not
residential so
when you look at what we did with
securitization lowering the cost of
consumers saving them hundreds of
millions of dollars
and the reality that uh the vast
majority 98
plus of residential homeowners are on a
fixed rate plan
and within our system if their provider
chooses to go up when their contracts up
they don't have to stay with that
provider they're able to go shop again
which is the beauty of our system that
we wanted to maintain
with while maintaining the financial
integrity of the system through the
securitization
i would also add that under hb16 that we
got rid of the wholesale index plans for
consumers and small businesses
so that those type of problems that were
unfortunately manifest during the winter
storm will not be seen
by residents by residential consumers
and small businesses going forward
so if i could make make clear what
senator was just talking about that is
what they passed eliminates price spikes
in the future
like what we saw in the past last
question
about the uh
uh yes the short answer is yes
we we raised uh there's a penalty matrix
that can go up to a million dollars per
violation which is a
pronounced enhancement over the current
penalty structure
uh that is the pillar structure now is
commensurate with what you see in ferc
the federal energy reliability council
there is a mandate on the part of the of
the legislature on to the puc as well as
well as the railroad commission
to actively with certain deadlines and
timelines to
evaluate this issue and to implement
appropriate rules and regulations
regarding weatherization
that is necessary to support maintain
and protect the grid in texas
well let me point out there's no one
sitting or standing here
who does not remember
that week none of us
miserable we don't want people to go
through that again
that's why we pass reforms to fix that
to make sure it will
never happen again we're not immune from
feeling the hurt and the pain and the
loss
of people across texas we know it we
feel it
we'll never forget it but we're going to
move forward
with the reforms that fix the system
and just to further what they were
saying on the teeth in this
they're already the the penalty matrix
it was mentioned there
you know i think looking back we saw the
failures of a system that was kind of a
suggestion
of sorts when it came to submitting
weatherization plans
emergency operation plans uh there's
actual requirements now
in that and there are abilities for
non-compliance uh and there will be
enforcement
the puc uh will be doing that there's
additional dollars that have been
appropriate and inspections as well
inspections as well
to be able to do that and so i'm very
confident there i would also mention
i've seen lots of reports
from we find folks that talked about how
we took it easy on
on natural gas and along the gas side i
wish you would go tell them that because
that's not what
whining is in my office that is not what
they're saying
and i think maybe part of where that
comes from is the confusion on what we
did
on limiting more to the mapping process
and identifying critical infrastructure
because again remember the whole goal
here
was to identify critical infrastructure
as it relates to the supply chain for
electric generation
which does not require weatherization of
every single wellhead
in this state and so we were very much
focused on and we accomplished in these
bills the very thing that we set out to
do and that
is to improve the reliability
of our system and shoring up that supply
chain
and so again same penalties applying uh
up to a million dollars a day
on those incidents can add up pretty
quickly and so i'm very confident folks
are going to comply because
if not it's going to be pretty beautiful
thank you all so much
so with regard to that uh that's
something that the department of state
health services
is in charge of and then they constantly
monitor it
and update it on an ongoing basis this
is a process you may have seen
the shs engage in in response to covet
and that they're doing the same thing
with regard to the winter storm and they
will provide
constant updates
closed captioning not available